>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Guy Lamolinara: Good
afternoon, everyone.
And thank you for
joining us today
for our Books and
Beyond Program.
I'm Guy Lamolinara from
the Center for the Book
and the Center for the Book is
co-sponsoring this talk today.
We're the division of the
Library that promotes books,
reading libraries and literacy,
and we also administer here
at the Library the Young
Readers Center and the Poetry
and Literature Center which are
over in the Jefferson Building.
Our mission is carried
out nationwide.
We do that here through
the National Center,
but we also have a State
Center in every state and D.C.,
and we also have one in
the U.S. Virgin Islands,
and we also have a partnership
of 80 like-minded literacy
organizations that we work with.
Additionally, we play
an important role
in the National Book Festival
and this year's Festival
is Saturday, September 24th
at the Washington
Convention Center.
And if you've never been to
the National Book Festival,
I urge you to come because
it's a wonderful event.
It's a great way to meet
your favorite authors.
And you could find out more
about the Book Festival
at loc.gov/bookfest.
Before we get started,
I just ask that you please turn
off all your electronic devices,
and I need to tell you that
we're recording today so that,
so if you ask a question you
will become part of our webcast.
And we also have
C-SPAN here today,
so you'll be part
of theirs as well.
You can view our webcast at
the Center for the Book website
which is read.gov, and
there you'll find more
than 250 book discussions that
we've had over many years.
Today's author's book will be
for sale just outside the
entrance to this room,
and following her presentation
she will be signing the book.
And it's also a chance
for you to talk
to her further about her work.
The chief criterion we have for
deciding which books we feature
in our series is that the writer
must have used the Library
of Congress, and in this case,
of course, that is obvious
with our Jacob Riis Collection.
This program is presented,
in fact, in conjunction
with the exhibition created
by the Interpretive Programs
Office here at the Library.
And this is the brochure
where you will find
out more information about
this great exhibition which is
over in the Jefferson Building.
The exhibition is
called Jacob Riis,
Revealing How the
Other Half Lives,
and it's a co-presentation
of the Library and Museum
of the City of New York.
And it's on display
in Jefferson Building
through September 5, 2016.
The exhibition and its
programming were made possible
by generous donors listed on the
back of this exhibition brochure
which you can find at
the exit to this event.
Today's program is co-sponsored
with the Interpretive Programs
Office, and thank you very much
for bringing that
program with us today.
Also with us is someone from the
Publishing Office who has worked
on the book, the beautiful book
that accompanies the exhibition,
and that is Aimee Hess
who is a writer/editor
in the Publishing Office where
she has worked since 2003.
Aimee has written two books
while there, Women Who Dare,
Helen Keller and Women
Who Dare, Margaret Mead .
And as an editor, Aimee
has worked on scores
of books relating to the Library
of Congress' vast collections
on topics ranging from
the Renaissance mapmaking
to our collections
of photographs documenting
Depression-era America.
In recent years, Aimee has
pioneered the Library's Digital
Publishing Program with the
2013 e-books, Great Photographs
from the Library of
Congress and Michigan-I-O,
Allan Lomax in the 1938 Library
of Congress Folklife
Exhibition .
She is currently editing the
forthcoming book, an e-book,
Homeplace which will highlight
the Michael Ford Collection
in the American Folklife Center.
Please welcome Aimee Hess.
[ Applause ]
>> Aimee Hess: Okay.
Thank you, everybody.
I'm here to introduce
Bonnie Yochelson
with whom I was lucky enough
to work on the Jacob Riis book,
Jacob A. Riis, Revealing
How the Other Half Lives .
Bonnie is originally
from the D.C. area,
but she's made her long-time
home in New York City.
She graduated from
Swarthmore College
and then proceeded a Master's
and a Doctorate in Art History
from New York University.
Early in her career, she
was back in D.C. working
in the print room at the
National Gallery of Art.
And from 1987 to 1991 she
was the Curator of Prints
and Photographs at the Museum
of the City of New York.
And that's where she
was first able to work
with the Jacob Riis
collection of photographs.
Since leaving the Museum, she's
been an independent Curator
and Photographic Historian
working with such institutions
as the New York Historical
Society,
the Columbia County
Historical Society,
and the South Street
Seaport Museum.
And since 1988, she has also
taught in the MFA Program
in the Department
of Photography,
Video and Related Media at
the School of Visual Arts
in New York where she curates
the annual Thesis Show,
and serves as a mentor
to graduating students.
In addition to the Thesis Show,
Bonnie has curated
numerous exhibitions,
including Esther Bubley,
American Photojournalist,
at the UBS Paine Webber Art
Gallery in New York in 2001.
That also travelled
to other cities.
And an exhibition titled
Alfred Stieglitz New York
at the South Street
Seaport Museum in 2010.
And, of course, she curated our
current Jacob A. Riis Exhibition
along with Barbara Thayer in our
Manuscript Division which opened
in a related but different
format at the Museum of the City
of New York before
opening here in April.
And it will also travel to
two locations in Denmark.
Bonnie is also the author
of many books including
Berniece Abbott,
Changing New York, Alfred
Stieglitz New York ,
and a co-author with
Daniel Czitrom
of Rediscovering Jacob Riis .
She's also written books on
the Clarence H. White School
of Photography and Esther
Bubbly among other subjects.
And, of course, Bonnie
also wrote the book
that we are all here for
today, Jacob A. Riis,
Revealing New York's
Other Half .
When Bonnie first began
working on Riis more
than two decades ago, Riis
was remembered primarily
as a photographer, and her
subsequent scholarship has
provided a much fuller
picture of Riis as an immigrant
who pulled himself up by his
bootstraps, a journalist,
an author, and a social reformer
who considered photographs
nothing more than a tool
to spread his message.
By seeing this fuller
picture of Riis
and by reading his
articles, books, lectures,
and the personal papers that
are housed here at the Library,
we can better understand
the issues
that New York's other
half actually faced --
poverty, poor housing
conditions, child labor,
lack of access to education,
homelessness, and disease.
Most, if not all of these
issues are still with us today
in one form or another,
which makes Riis's work
and Bonnie's more
relevant than ever.
As an editor, I have worked
with a lot of different authors,
and since I have the
stage I just want
to take this opportunity to say
what an absolute pleasure it was
to work with Bonnie and how
much I admire her as a scholar
and an independent -- and
a museum professional.
It takes a certain kind
of person to be successful
as an independent scholar,
someone who can manager her
own time, meet deadlines,
forge connections and
partnerships, and find money
to get big projects done.
While I was spending much of
my time on this one project,
she was simultaneously
conducting original research,
writing unique exhibition lists
for different venues, teaching
and coordinating the Senior
Thesis Show at the School
of Visual Arts, all
while writing this book
and compiling the first-ever
catalog of Riis's photographs.
In the years it has taken to
get these exhibitions mounted
and this book published, Bonnie
has worn every single type
of hat in the business, and none
of this could have been possible
without her talent, energy,
and passion for her subject.
So, with that, I will let
Bonnie take the stage.
[ Applause ]
>> Bonnie Yochelson:
Aimee, thank you so much.
I'm moved.
Thank you very much.
Welcome everyone.
Okay. So I'm going
to read pretty much,
and let's see what
we have to say here.
I'm going to repeat a
little bit of what Aimee did
to just make sure that we
understand how these different
parts of this project
fit together.
The Jacob Riis Exhibition now on
view in the Jefferson Building
of the Library of Congress is
the result of a collaboration
of the past several years
between the Library and Museum
of the City of New York.
The Museum's own -- owns
the Riis's photographs
of New York City's slums
in the late 19th century.
These photographs are
the earliest evidence
of the disastrous effects of the
forces of modernity on New York,
whose slums were the worst
on Earth at that time.
Because the city's economy
was expanding so rapidly,
it became a magnet
for rural Americans
and European immigrants
seeking jobs and a better life.
And although jobs
were plentiful,
the city did not have
the housing, sanitation,
or transportation system
to meet their basic needs.
New arrivals lived in
hastily-built tenements
with little or no
plumbing, and wages
and rents were exploitative.
People of all ages,
including young children,
worked in factories and did
piecework in their homes.
Education was not mandatory
and there were no public parks
or playgrounds where
children could play safely.
Riis's photographs, taken
between 1887 and 1895,
depicted all these urban ills.
The collection is small.
Riis only took about 250
pictures of New York.
But it is unique, world
famous, and in constant demand.
So just as a kind
of signature image,
I'm showing you Bandit's Roost
which is Riis's most
famous picture.
It shows some Italian
toughs in an alley
in a neighborhood
called Mulberry Bend
which he wrote much about
and which was very
close to his office.
Let's see if I can get
this going properly.
And just to show you
the sort of sense
in which Riis's images have
been thoroughly disseminated,
this is -- shows a
recreation of Bandit's Roost
by Martin Scorsese in his 2002
film, Gangs of New York .
Riis is equally celebrated
for his first book,
How the Other Half Lives which
presented a passionate argument
for addressing this crisis.
Riis was a journalist by
trade, and after years
of covering the crime beat in
New York, he began to write
about urban poverty and the
latest ideas to remedy it.
His book has remained in print
since it first appeared in 1890,
and it's become a landmark
text in American history.
This is -- shows you the
first edition of the book.
It's very small.
I don't know.
I should know this right
now, like 5 by 9 inches.
And this shows you
a recent edition.
You can see how it's --
you know, it's even
called out on the cover,
"A Jacob Riis Classic."
Interestingly, a photograph
on the front is not
by Riis [laughter].
But it's in the picture
of tenements.
The Library of Congress owns
the bulk or Riis's archive
which includes notes,
manuscripts,
off-prints of articles,
annotated scrapbooks
of newspaper clippings,
family letters,
expense books, and much more.
And just again, to give you some
idea, this is the first page
of a small scrapbook in which
Riis collected the press
comments on his very
first lecture.
It reads here, "Press comments
on the lecture, "The Other Half,
How It Lives and Dies in
New York," illustrated
with a hundred photographic
views by Jacob A. Riis,
delivered for the first
time, January 25, 1888,
before the American
Photographers Association
at 122 W. 36th Street,
New York."
So, this gives you a
sense of how aware he was
of keeping track of his
career for posterity.
The current exhibition, which
opened last fall in New York,
as Aimee said, and will
travel this fall to Denmark,
which is Riis's native country,
brings together the
Museum's photographs
and the Library's archive
for the very first time.
In each venue the show
takes a different form,
but each offers a rich
portrait of Riis and his legacy.
I first encountered
Riis's photographs in 1987
when I took a job as Curator
of Prints and Photographs
at the Museum of the
City of New York.
Riis was a professional
journalist,
not a professional
photographer, indeed,
not even a serious
amateur photographer.
Yet he is considered one
of the great pioneers
in the history of the medium.
This is the puzzle that has
kept me working on Riis on
and off for, I have to
say, nearly 30 years.
Just a shocking thought.
But now, finally, I am done.
Today I would like to share
with you my journey with Riis
and summarize my understanding
of his accomplishments
as a reformer and
a photographer.
Before becoming Curator
at the Museum I worked
in the Photography Departments
of three art museums.
These museums collected
individual prints
by photographers who used the
camera to create works of art.
The Riis collection was
unlike any I had ever seen.
It consisted of 415
glass negatives,
many of them copy negatives of
prints by other photographers,
326 glass lantern slides made by
commercial photography studios,
and 191 vintage prints, a
handful from Riis's negatives,
and the remainder by unknown
professional photographers.
The museum was the sole
repository of Riis's photographs
which consisted of this
assortment of odd stuff.
The record search at
the museum indicated
that the collection
came there in 1945,
31 years after Riis
died, and was given
by his son, Roger William Riis.
The story behind this gift
only created more questions.
In the 1940s, photographer
Alexander Alland [assumed
spelling], Senior had
noticed that the title page
of How the Other
Half Lives announced
that the book's illustrations
were based
on photographs by the author.
Searching for these photographs,
Alland contacted Riis's son
and convinced him to ask the
current owners of the house
in Queens where he grew up
if he might look in the attic
for his father's photographs.
There he found a box which
contained the 450 negatives,
326 lantern slides,
and 191 vintage prints
that now comprise
the Riis collection.
The very fact that Riis did not
save his photographs is the most
important clue to what
he thought of them.
In contrast to the photographs,
Riis organized, annotated all
of his papers for posterity.
His family eventually gave
most of them to the Library
of Congress and a
smaller portion
to the New York Public Library.
When Riis sold the family home
and moved to Massachusetts
in 1912, he left the
photographs in the attic.
The contents of the box in the
attic was given to the Museum
of the City of New York
because Alland teamed
up with the curator at the time,
Grace Mayor, who prepared --
and together they
prepared an exhibition,
"The Battle of the Slum" which,
in 1947 introduced Riis's
photographs to the world.
The show featured 50
beautiful prints made by Alland
from Riis's negatives
with quotations culled
by Mayor from Riis's writings.
This comparison of an
Alland print on the left
and the contact print
from Riis's negatives --
the contact print
from this negative
in the Riis collection gives you
some idea of Alland's artistry.
Alland doubled the size
of the vintage prints,
which you cannot really see
here because I'm just fooling
around with, you
know, reproductions
on this -- in the PowerPoint.
But which you can
see is get some sense
of his darkroom wizardry in
which Alland created rich blacks
and detailed highlights.
He also cropped out the
foreground of the image,
eliminating the areas
that were out of focus
which brought our
attention to the ragpickers
in the middle distance.
Let's see if I can
show you this.
He cropped out this basically
out-of-focus foreground so that
in his foreground you get a
closeup view of these ragpickers
that are sitting here among
rags against this wall,
so that it's a much
more successful
and interesting composition
by having cropped the image
that way, which is
typical of what Alland did.
A huge success.
The exhibition was
widely covered
in the photographic press,
and Riis entered the history
of photograph as a
pioneer of the medium.
In 1973, Alland published a
very well-researched biography
which featured his prints
from Riis's negatives
and was titled Jacob A. Riis,
Photographer and Citizen .
Without Alland,
Riis's photographs
would have been lost.
But, because of him,
Riis became known
as a modern documentary
photographer, which he was not.
In the 1950s, as interest
in Riis's photographs grew,
the Museum had to provide
access to the collection,
most of which was made of glass
and could not be shown
in original form.
To facilitate researchers
and provide prints
for reproduction the Museum
staff photographer made study
prints from all the negatives.
Like Alland's prints, these
were eight-by-ten enlargements.
But, unlike Alland's prints,
they were poor quality.
This was the situation when I
arrived at the museum in 1987.
Because of Alland's rescue and
promotion of Riis's photographs,
Riis was considered a
major modern photographer.
But because of the
museum's stewardship,
the public saw only poor study
prints made from the negatives,
and they knew nothing of the
additional images available only
as lantern slides
or vintage prints.
I'm wondering -- okay.
Sorry. I'll go back to that one.
To compound the problem,
many photographs made
by Riis were attributed
to him because many
of the negatives
were copies of prints
by other photographers
that he acquired.
So here is -- this is
where I need this pointer.
If you can see, this is a --
Riis has pinned up Jessie Tarbox
Beals photograph with thumbtacks
and rephotographed it.
So you can see the
thumbtacks here, so.
And then -- and the reason he
did this is because he wanted
to have a lantern slide made,
and I'm showing you
the lantern slide
on the right, for his lectures.
This is a scene of a family
making artificial flowers
in their tenement home.
And this picture was --
because this is a negative,
it's a copy negative,
this was cropped
so that you don't see the
thumbtacks and, you know,
printed the same size
as all the others.
And so for many, many years
this image was attributed
to Riis even though it's
actually got Jessie Tarbox
Beals' signature
on the negative,
right down here [laughter].
So those were the
kind of, you know,
problems that the
collection presented.
So, generally, curators have
enormous interpretive discretion
with collections, just by virtue
of selecting them and figuring
out how to present them.
This case, this collection,
presented me, as the curator,
with a sort of alarming sense of
responsibility because by having
to essentially put aside these
study prints and determine how
to create new prints and how
to make the glass
lantern slides available,
as well as the information
and the negatives
and the vintage prints, I was
really kind of creating --
had the responsibility
to create Riis's work,
which was daunting,
to say the least.
In 1994, and by this
time I was not on staff,
but I was supervising
this project,
the museum received a grant
from the National Endowment
For the Humanities to create
a database of the collection,
to make color transparencies
of the lantern slides,
and to make contact prints, four
by five inches, the same size
as the negatives, on
Printing-Out Paper,
the type used in Riis's day.
The goal was to create
prints that looked
like the vintage
prints that we did have
in the collection and elsewhere.
This was in the wrong
order, but I'll show you.
This is an example of one of
the handful of vintage prints
that are in the collection
that are in decent condition.
So this is a contact print, four
by five inches, the same size
as the negative, mounted
on a piece of cardboard.
So these vintage material
prints, as they are called,
are what the public now sees,
and there's a large sampling
of these on view now in
the print exhibition.
That year, 1994,
I wrote an article
that explained the NEH access
and preservation project.
It was titled, "What Are the
Photographs of Jacob Riis?"
And it began with a hand-colored
lantern slide of Bandit's Roost.
You can see that here.
This image was meant to
surprise and provoke the viewer.
You think you know
Bandit's Roost?
Look at this.
And that's what the
slide looks like.
So this is the kind of
material that was buried
because the lantern slides were
not available to researchers.
But this slide is an
example of how Riis's --
it doesn't look anything like a
modern documentary photographer.
There's images like this.
With the new facsimiles and
the database as a foundation,
it became clear to me that
the collection was not a
photographer's body of work,
or oeuvre as sometimes called,
but the raw material for
Riis's articles and lectures.
For him, the final product was
the words and pictures together.
What was needed was a study of
the photographs to delineate
which pictures he took,
when, and for what purpose,
and which pictures he acquired,
when, and for what purpose.
The detective work consisted
to creating a research folder
for each image and collecting
in the folder each version
of the image -- the
negative, any lantern slides,
and any prints --
along with photocopies
of each published
version of each image.
The illustrations in Riis's
articles, dozens of them
which appeared in New
York daily newspapers
and nationally-circulating
magazines could be gleaned
from the offprints and
scrapbooks in the Riis paper
in the Library of Congress.
In 1976, the Riis papers had
been microfilmed, and I was able
to purchase a copy of
the eight rolls of film
which became my bible.
And any of you have
had any experience
with microfilm know how
unpleasant an experience
that is, but is was vitally
important for being able
to identify, match up
which pictures were taken
for which publication.
The content of these research
folders forms the basis
of the current catalog.
In 1997, however, I did not
aim to produce a catalog.
I aimed to produce a narrative
about Riis's photographic
practice,
and I hoped to place
the five years
in which he used the
camera within the context
of his 40 years as a journalist.
As Aimee explained, I'm an art
historian not an historian,
and for the latter task
I was not equipped.
I did not understand
Riis's world which was not
that of an artist, but
of journalism, politics,
law enforcement, and housing
at the turn of the century.
Doing some preliminary
research I learned
that Riis was an important
figure in American history,
regardless of the photographs,
but for his writings
and his activism.
To get my bearings in
the history of the period
and to bridge the dialog
in two disparate fields,
I needed the help
of an historian.
So I reached out to Dan Czitrom,
a Professor of American History
at Mount Holyoke College.
As independent scholars, we
were awarded an NEH Grant
in collaborative research
to prepare a book on Riis
which was published in 2007, and
came out in paperback in 2014.
And that's this little book.
While Dan and I were working on
our book, the museum embarked
on a massive digitization
of its photo collections
and the Riis collection
among others is now fully
available online.
As incredible as this
accomplishment is,
it highlighted a problem.
The information that accompanied
the digital images online was
the preliminary research
done in 1994 as part
of that original NEH Access
and Preservation Grant.
The museum was sending serious
researchers to me, personally,
to help them better understand
what they encountered online,
which sent me time and
again to my research files.
I realized that there was a
real need for a complete catalog
of the collection that would
place Riis's photographs
in the context of his writings
and sort out the knotty problems
of attribution; that is, to
explain which picture he took,
which he asked others to take
for him, and when, and why.
In 2012 I offered the contents
of my files to the museum
and asked if it was interested
in supporting the
publication of a catalog.
The museum decided to sponsor
the catalog, and a primary goal
of the catalog is to
contrast Riis's photographs
with the published
illustrations,
which predated the accurate
halftones that became standard
by the turn of the
century, by 1900.
This required extensive
photography
of Riis's articles and books.
That is, it required reliance
on the Jacob Riis papers
here in the library.
A dialog between the two
institutions resulted
in a partnership to
jointly publish the catalog.
For me this was a godsend.
After years of peering at
smudgy images on microfilm,
I was able to examine the
original scrapbooks and letters.
It was as if I finally met this
man I had studied for so long.
As the Museum and Library
worked out a formal agreement,
I began meeting with Aimee
who edited the catalog,
Barbara Behr [assumed
spelling], Curator in the Museum
in the Manuscripts and Archives
Division, and Cheryl Regan,
Director of Exhibitions.
They were invaluable partners
who not only brought the catalog
and the exhibition into being,
but enhanced my understanding
of Riis.
And Beverly Brannon also, who
is a Curator in the Prints
and Photograph Department,
helped me with the --
was invaluable in helping
me with the Riis photographs
that are also part of
the collection here.
Having told my Riis story,
let me brief you of the story
of Riis as I've come
to understand it.
Jacob August Riis was born
in 1849 in Ribe, Denmark,
a cathedral town more
connected to the medieval past
than the industrial present.
Riis was a restless,
even rebellious child
who at age 20 left
home for America,
a place about which
he knew nothing.
In his autobiography
he mentioned
that he loved James
Fenimore Cooper's stories
of American Indians.
And when he arrived in New
York he purchased a gun
which he brandished and narrowly
escaped getting arrested.
Although Riis's example is
perhaps more colorful than most,
his desire to reinvent himself
in a new land was a
common 19th century story.
America was built by waves
of European immigrants --
Irish, German, Chinese,
Scandinavians, Italians,
and Jews.
Between 1870 and 1900, a tenth
of all Danes left
home for America.
This is one of -- these, by
the way, are Riis's slides
in his own autobiographical
lecture.
These are a copy of
his slides which are
in this collection here.
Most Danish immigrants travelled
to the Midwest as homesteaders,
and in many instances they
founded their own communities.
By contrast, Riis spent five
years wandering from place
to place, job to job, failing
to establish a foothold
time and again.
The immigrant sense of
alienation, of being caught
between old and the new,
and feeling misunderstood was
perhaps extreme in Riis's case.
Explaining why he slept on
this gravestone in Brunswick,
New Jersey, Riis wrote, "The
night dews and the snakes
and the dogs that kept sniffing
and growling had made me tired
of sleeping in the fields.
The dead were much
better company.
They minded their own business
and let a fellow alone."
What motivated Riis to
continue was his determination
to win the hand of Elizabeth
Gertz, a girl from Ribe,
his hometown, who was socially
beyond his reach there.
Against all odds,
she was unmarried
when he asked for
her hand in 1875.
That's after his five
years of failure.
And she accepted despite the
fact that she barely knew him.
He brought Elizabeth
back to America.
They had five children.
And Riis settled the family
in a house with a large garden
in Richmond Hill, Queens.
Riis succeeded in fulfilling
every immigrant's dream
of middle class respectability.
And this is perhaps
not that descriptive,
but one of the most
charming pictures
of his family snapshots
that he took.
His house is -- you can
see in the background,
on this large property they had.
That's his daughter,
Katie, with her pet goat.
And you can see Riis's
shadow in the front
where he's holding the camera.
Riis finally -- okay.
Riis finally found his way in
America as a newspaper man.
In 1876 he landed a job
as a police reporter
for the New York Tribune and
later for the Evening Sun .
The daily police beat
provided his base salary
for 23 years until 1899.
This was the era of
yellow journalism
in which New York's many
daily papers competed
for screaming headlines
and sensational stories.
Riis explained, "The
police reporter
on a newspaper is the one who
gathers and handles all the news
that means trouble to someone,
the murders, fires, suicides,
robberies, and all that sort,
before it gets into court."
Police reporters shared an
office at 301 Mulberry Street,
across the street from
Police Headquarters
in the middle of
a six-ward slum.
For eight years Riis
worked the nightshift
and became box reporter
through sheer hard work.
He also honed his
storytelling skills,
although his articles
often read like tales
by Hans Christian
Anderson, a fellow Dane.
But he insisted they
were true fact.
"I cannot [inaudible],"
he claimed.
Next to a clipping in one of
his scrapbooks Riis wrote,
"This was the last
Christmas story I wrote
for my paper, The
Evening Sun .
They laughed it to scorn in the
office and made no end of fun
of it, and yet, of all the
stories I have written,
I like it best.
It moved me more deeply
than any of the rest."
So, in this picture,
which is also
in the Library's collection,
that's Riis back there,
essentially waiting for his
from Police Headquarters
across the street.
And this picture's kind
of fascinating because --
and it's on view right
now in the exhibit --
because of this wall
of photo reproductions
from magazines that
covers the wall.
In 1884, Riis moved from
the night to the dayshift.
And as he said, "My
eggs hatched."
He began by covering
the meetings
of the 1884 Tenement House
Commission which convened
at Police Headquarters.
In this way, Riis learned of the
community of philanthropists,
engineers, and architects
who aimed
to change the lives
of tenement dwellers.
He became a student, an
advocate of the latest ideas
in housing reform which soon
expanded to include education,
public parks and
playgrounds, public health
and immigration policy.
In 1887, Riis read about the
German invention of flash powder
in which a powerful burst
of light could illuminate
scenes photographed in the dark.
He had the idea that he
could use photographs
to show what his
words could only tell.
Although he had no intention
of photographing himself,
and at first he didn't, this
was a truly revolutionary idea.
About this picture, Five
Cents A Spot, Riis wrote,
"I recall a midnight
expedition to the Mulberry Bend
with the Sanitary Police
that had turned up a couple
of characteristic
cases of overcrowding.
In one instance, two rooms that
should, at most, have held four
or five sleepers were
found to contain 15,
a week-old baby among them.
Most of them were
lodgers and slept there
for five cents a spot.
There was no pretense of beds.
When the report was submitted to
the Health Board the next day,
it did not make much
of an impression.
These things rarely do, put in
mere words, until my negatives,
still dripping from
the darkroom,
came to reinforce them.
From them there was no appeal."
Riis first showed his
photographs in January, 1888,
at the monthly meeting of
the Lantern Slide Committee
of the Society of Amateur
Photographers of New York.
The meeting was arranged
by two society members
who were interested in the
new flashlight photography
and had helped Riis take
his first photographs.
Titling his talk, How the Other
Half Lives and Dies in New York,
Riis showed 100 slides,
spoke for two hours,
and invited his friends
from the press.
The extensive press coverage led
to his delivering his lecture
to various church groups.
In the following year he
was asked by two editors
of Scribner's Magazine
to write an article
for this prestigious
illustrated journal
that circulated nationally.
In 1890, Scribner's published
a book-length version,
How the Other Half Lives which
became a national best-seller.
This book was what
Riis is most known for,
and is often considered
the beginning
of modern photojournalism.
However, the book is
in many ways unmodern,
or at least modern in ways
we no longer relate to.
The revolutionary
flashlight photographs
such as Five Cents A Spot
remain disturbing, even today.
However, they have
been rightly criticized
for portraying the city's
homeless as hapless victims
who were photographed
without their permission.
Indeed, Riis gave
them a good scare.
He burst into the room with what
he called a raiding party --
two photographers, a Sanitary
Policeman, and himself --
and set off an explosion.
On several occasions the
combustible flash powder caused
a fire.
During Riis's lifetime, the only
times his photographs were seen
as photographs were in
his lectures, like this,
projected on a wall, when they
were projected on a screen
or wall for a live audience.
In his article and
books on the other hand,
they were most often
copied as wood engravings.
This explains why the
photographs were almost never
mentioned in the dozen of
reviews of Five Cents A Spot.
And this shows Five Cents a
Spot in the wood engravings
that has appeared in the book.
For a century after
it was written,
How the Other Half Lives was
praised as a call to conscience.
But in the 1990s many critics
began to fault Riis for relying
on racial stereotypes.
And this is a picture of
an opium den in Chinatown.
Indeed, the book is
organized as a slum tour
in which Riis leads his
audience through neighborhoods
of Italians, Jews,
Chinese, et cetera.
In his day, the slum tour was an
established literary tradition
which grew out of
actual guided tours
of New York's neighborhoods,
rich and poor.
Matthew Hale Smith's Sunshine
and Shadow of New York written
in 1869, a generation before,
is a classic of the genre.
And you can see here,
this shows --
the sunshine is the
picture of a wealthy --
of a huge mansion
on Fifth Avenue,
and the shadow shows a slum.
This actually looks
like Five Points.
Yeah, it would have
been Five Points,
which was the most famous
New York slum of the time.
Riis's book married the
voyeuristic slum tour
with a Christian sermon.
How the Other Half Lives
starts and ends with passages
from the parable, "A Poem"
by James Russell Lowell,
in which Christ chastises
men of [inaudible]
for ignoring their less
fortunate brethren.
The book ends with
Lowell's question,
"Think ye that building shall
endure which shelters the noble
and crushes the poor?"
It was Riis's genius
to walk the tightrope
between popular entertainment
and moral uplift.
For a 21st century
reader, the book is a relic
of Victorian sensibility.
Most discussions of Riis do not
go beyond How the Other Half
Lives .
But the book, which
was published in 1890,
when Riis was 41 years old,
marks only the beginning
of his reform work.
His later career,
which is less known,
sheds light on other
features of modernity.
After the success of his first
book, Riis immediately got
to work on a sequel, The
Children of the Poor ,
which was first published in
Scribner's Magazine and then
as a full-length book in 1892.
And this shows the opening page.
The picture on the
left is unrelated.
It's for another article.
But this shows you the
first page of The Children
of the Poor in Scribner's ,
and features very
worked-over halftone.
Again, this is this
transitional moment
in reproductive technology,
of Little Katie, who I'm going
to introduce you to in a moment.
Perhaps because his
subjects were children
or because he grew more
comfortable with the camera,
Riis changed his
approach to photographing.
Typical of the photographs
in Children
of the Poor is Little
Katie whose picture
in a heavily reworked halftone
opens the Scribner's article.
Katie was a nine-year-old
who Riis met on a visit
to the West 52nd Street
Industrial School founded
by the Children's Aid Society
to provide classes for children
who did not attend
public school.
Unlike the raiding party of the
earlier flashlight photographs,
Riis introduced himself to
Katie and interviewed her.
He learned that when her mother
died her father took a new wife
and she and her older
siblings moved out.
Katie kept house for them
while they worked in factories.
"About Katie," Riis remarked,
"this picture shows what
a sober, patient, sturdy,
little thing she was with
that dull life wearing
on her day-by-day.
She got right up when asked
and stood for her picture
without a question
and without a smile.
'What kind of work
do you do,' I asked,
thinking to interest
her while I made ready.
'I scrub,' she replied promptly.
And her look guaranteed
that what she scrubbed
came out clean."
This new approach, in which
the photographer shows respect
for his subject and gives
her a voice, is more in line
with current values and
representational practices.
The book, which combined
these word and image portraits
with Board of Health
statistics and a survey
of charity programs, was
a commercial failure.
Between 1891 and 1893, Riis
used the camera regularly
as an extension of his writing.
While preparing The Children of
the Poor he also took a series
of photographs of three news --
for three newspaper
exposes dealing
with threats to public health.
He photographed 11
Riverside dumps to show
that the law banning
ragpickers from living
in the dumps went unenforced.
He went upstate to
the Croton Reservoir,
the source of New York's water
supply, to document industrial
and agricultural pollution.
And he photographed
the abysmal conditions
of nine police station
lodging houses,
the only municipal shelters
available to the homeless.
This was investigative
journalism in the modern sense.
But Riis was too far
ahead of his time.
And this is one of
the photographs
of the lodging houses
that he took in 1892.
This is the New York
Tribune from January, 1892,
an article about
these lodging houses.
The reproductive technology of
the time kept his photographs
from being seen at
full strength.
Newspapers made single-line
wood engravings
after the photographs,
which did not look
like photographs at all.
So just -- that's the
way the picture was seen.
Because of an outbreak of
typhus in the lodging houses,
Riis gave a lantern
slide lecture
at the Academy of
Medicine in 1893.
Other than this one lecture,
the public never saw
these photographs.
Perhaps for this reason Riis
gave up newspaper photography
in 1893 and used the camera
only occasionally thereafter.
Riis's life took
a new turn in 1895
when a good government
mayor, William L. Strong,
defeated the Tammany
Hall political machine
and Strong appointed
Theodore Roosevelt
as his Police Commissioner.
Having read how the other
half lived, Roosevelt walked
across the street from
Police Headquarters
to Riis's Mulberry Street
office to seek his advice.
The two men became very close
friends, and for a short
but significant period Riis
had access to political power.
Thanks to Riis's advocacy,
mostly behind the scenes,
the worst of the old tenements,
the infamous Gotham Court
and the Mott Street Barracks,
and this is a picture taken
on the roof of the
Mott Street Barracks
where families are
basically escaping the heat
of the interior for the roof.
These big horrible
barracks, Gotham Court
and Mott Street,
were demolished.
The police lodging
houses were closed.
And the notorious
Mulberry Bend was condemned
to construct a small park.
This is Riis's photograph
of Mulberry Bend.
It actually shows the bend in
the street, which is still --
it's still a street
of tenements.
You can still see it.
And this is the park
that replaced it.
This is a photograph
from 1901, not by Riis.
What I mean by saying it's still
there is that the park is on --
this is trying, this is trying
to -- this row is still there.
Riis also convinces city
to condemn buildings
on the Lower East Side to
build two more small parks,
Hamilton Fish Park and
Seward Park which continue
to serve local residents today.
By the end of the
Strong Administration,
which was only one
term of two years,
before Tammany was
elected back in,
Riis began to take
a retrospective view
of his decade of reform.
In 1900 he published a book
called The Ten Years' War .
That's 1890 when his first
book was published in 1900.
And 1902 a follow-up which
is essentially the same book
with more illustrations called
The Battle of the Slum .
Also by 1900 the
photographic halftone
in which the tonal value
of photographs could be
economically reproduced
with text on the same
page was nearly universal
in magazines and books.
As a result, there was an
increased demand for photographs
of all sorts, including
photographs Riis needed
for his new books.
Professionals filled
the new demand and Riis,
rather than taking
new photographs,
began to collect them.
Half of his collection consists
of photographs of new schools,
model tenements,
public parks, et cetera,
by professional photographers.
In this typical example,
Riis wrote an article
for Garden Magazine about the
Jacob Riis Settlement House,
a Social Service
Organization on Henry Street
on the Lower East Side, which
he helped found in the 1880s,
and which was named
for him in 1901.
It moved to Long
Island City in 1951
and still provides
essential services
for the community there.
The magazine sent a
professional photographer
to take these pictures
for the article.
And Riis had lantern slides
made from them for his lecture.
So these are lantern slides
in the collection made
from the photographs
of this article.
Yeah, I think I just
showed you the ones.
When Riis quit his
newspaper job in 1899,
he began to spend several
months a year travelling all
over the country delivering
illustrated lectures
to fill in for lost income.
Lecture bureaus arranged
scheduling and billing
for this popular form of
educational entertainment.
For each of his books, Riis
developed a slide lecture
and travelled the country,
very like today's book
tours or a Ted Talk.
So this is actually
a lantern slide,
but it was basically a
photograph of a poster
for his lecture, "The Battle of
the Slum, Illustrated by scores
of original stereopticon
pictures of New York City life,"
is what the title says.
Oh boy. That is terrible
[laughter].
It's actually -- it's
from a microfilm,
but I'll just tell you about it.
Riis -- I don't have the
original because it's --
well, it's in the collection.
It wasn't microfilmed at all.
This is from a microfilm from
another -- from Chicago Library.
Because it was so big,
it was just in shreds,
and sadly not copied here.
But, anyway.
Riis's use of the mass media,
including lecture circuit,
made Riis the nation's face
and voice of urban reform.
So here's a great
story about this image.
The Chicago Tribune ,
for example, ran a series
of seven full-page articles,
"The Story of the Slum,"
which in -- seven weeks in
a row, the entire first page
of their editorial section.
And so this is the first one,
and it's called "The Story
of the Slum, Part One."
And it shows some of Riis's
pictures and his portrait,
all in wood engravings after
his -- after the photographs.
So for this Riis was paid $1000
which was about $29,000 today.
So it gives you some sense
of his national reputation.
Let's get rid of that
terrible picture.
In 1901, Riis published
his autobiography,
The Making of an American
, a confessional test built
around two characters,
his wife, Elizabeth,
and his friend, Teddy Roosevelt.
The book was published on
Riis's 25th wedding anniversary
and just months after
Roosevelt became President,
a stroke of fate due
to the assassination
of President William McKinley.
The story of a poor
young foreigner
who became a happily married
father of five and a visitor
to the White House proved
irresistible to the public.
Riis published a dozen
books, but only two,
How The Other Half
Lives , the slum tour
and Christian sermon
combined , and The Making
of an American , the sort
of confessional story of rise
from poverty to the White
House, were best-sellers.
And this is a silver wedding
anniversary photograph of Riis
and his wife actually taken
by a well-known portrait
photographer,
Gertrude [inaudible].
Riis's autobiography
-- let me see.
I'm sorry.
So. And here is a copy -- a
cover of the first edition
of The Making of an American .
Riis's autobiography
has been compared
to Horatio Alger's
contemporaneous rags-to-riches
stories and to the
American dream,
a term not coined though
until the Depression.
The book also bears comparison
to our own confessional culture.
Indeed, Riis was mocked in the
press for telling all he knows
and feels, which makes
you feel sorry for him.
And his children were
teased, he explains,
that their father was a bum
once people knew the story.
Riis no longer -- no
doubt enjoyed his fame,
but he used his candor
to further his cause,
not unlike today's celebrities
who reveal their histories
of sexual abuse or addiction to
encourage public understanding
of challenging issues.
This amusing caricature of Riis
pounding on a lectern appeared
with a review of his
lecture in the San Jose,
California Mercury in 1911.
The reporter noted, "Simple
as the story was told,
it held the listeners rapt.
'If,' said Riis in closing,
'the story of one plain
immigrant lad helps you to look
with kind eyes on one
little unfortunate lad,
I shall think my
words well-spoken.'"
So, that's my view of --
my summary of his career
and how the photographs
enter in.
So this is the current
book, the catalogue.
And so, to conclude, let
me just say a few words
about the catalogue.
In the 1990s, when I was working
with Dan Czitrom on our book,
I felt that a complete catalogue
of the Riis collection would
send the wrong message.
A complete catalogue or,
as art historians call it,
a catalogue raisonne, identifies
and describes the complete
works of an artist.
I was concerned that a book
of this sort would reinforce
the incorrect notion,
current at the time, that Riis
was a photographic artist.
Indeed, I had just finished
a complete catalogue
of another major collection
belonging to the Museum
of the City of New York,
"Bernice Abbott's
Changing New York."
Unlike Riis, Abbott was a
professional photographer
and an avant-garde
artist who created one
of the great artworks of body
support of the 20th century.
Photographing New York for
10 years, from 1929 to 1939,
she defined changing New York
by making 305 signed exhibition
prints which she presented
to the museum, who was
the project's sponsor.
This kind of artistic intent
is exactly what Riis lacked.
But over time, the need for a
complete catalogue became clear.
As I mentioned earlier, scholars
need to know the who, when,
why story behind
each photograph.
The book provides a basis for
further research in a variety
of fields, especially
history and media studies.
Take Bandit's Roost for example.
This most famous of Riis's
photographs was not taken
by him.
It was taken for him in
1887 by the two amateurs
who arranged his first
talk at the Society
of Amateur Photographers
of New York.
And it was made with
a stereoscopic camera
which had two lenses
mounted side-by-side
to produce two images
on a glass negative.
At some point this negative
was divided in half,
and that's why you see the
two images separated here.
And they differ slightly
because the lens
on the left shows you more
information on the left.
There's a mother and two little
children here on the left.
And on the right you have more
information featuring this tough
Italian dude with a bowler hat.
Riis's four lantern slides
of Bandit's Roost were made
from the right side,
featuring the young tough
which better illustrated his
point about the dangerousness
of the back alleys
of Mulberry Bend.
This kind of close visual
reading is essential
for scholars seeking
to understand Riis
as a photographer.
The catalogue also serves,
though, the interests
of the general reader.
Riis was wrong that his
photographs were of no value
when seen apart from
his arguments.
But they are of much greater
value when paired with them.
Oh, sorry.
That's a stereoscopic camera,
so you understand what I
mean about the two lenses.
"Five Cents A Spot" is much more
moving when we learn from Riis
that 15 people, including a
week-old baby, were sleeping
in that illegal lodging house.
And when we learned that Little
Katie was nine years old,
that her mother had died,
and her father had
abandoned his children,
and that she kept
house for her siblings,
the photograph becomes
much more meaningful.
By studying each of Riis's
photographs and pairing it
with his words, the
catalogue brings us closer
to the empathetic experience
that Riis sought to inspire
in his audiences more
than a century ago.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
I think --
>> Guy Lamolinara:
There's time for questions.
>> Bonnie Yochelson: You
have a few questions?
If anybody has any.
Could we turn some lights on
because I can't see anyone?
Yes.
>> What edition of How The
Other Half Lives has the
best photographs?
>> Bonnie Yochelson:
That is a very good
and complicated questions.
It depends what you
mean by the best.
You know, I'm -- there've
been -- there are so --
when you go on Amazon, and look
at How The Other Half Lives ,
there are so many editions.
The Museum has only been giving
out these vintage
material prints of late.
But, honestly, I think the
best -- well, before you said,
which has the best photographs,
if you had just said
which is the best edition,
I would say the one
that copies the original book,
that shows the wood engravings
and the lantern slides,
because then you --
it puts the book in context.
There was, in the '70s, an
edition photographed with 100 --
an edition of the
book photographed --
cheap, but large
reproductions by Dover Press.
You know, very inexpensive,
very accessible edition.
That has 100 pictures in it.
They're just chosen
arbitrarily by an editor,
but it shows you
a lot of pictures.
There have been -- but I would
say there have been other
editions that have tried to use
the modern prints with the book,
but they kind of destroy
the book as an entity
by interjecting the modern
photographs with the story.
So I don't have -- I sort
of don't like those books,
and I haven't really -- sorry,
I've never really thought
about how to answer
your question.
It's the facsimiles of the
original that strike me
as the best way to
look at the books.
And all the pictures are
available on the Internet,
on the Museum's website, so
that if there's any image
that you're interested in, you
could see a beautiful, you know,
high-res scan of it on
the Museum's website
of any individual picture.
Yes.
>> Let me ask you.
You said that -- I'll just
start at the beginning.
[Inaudible] was just
using [inaudible] what you
were saying.
But afterwards you kind
of started to, I suppose,
[inaudible] there may
be one [inaudible].
Was he ever -- did he ever talk
about photographers at that time
that influenced him, or did he
ever show any interest in that,
or was it just that, you know,
he needed [inaudible]
his pocket?
>> Bonnie Yochelson:
He wasn't interested --
he didn't think about
authorship at all.
I mean, he was not
interested in making pictures.
You know, his pictures were
represented however a publisher
wanted to show them, you know.
So he would give them a
print, one of those prints
like the vintage print I
showed you mounted on board,
and then they would have an
artist interpret it however
that magazine wanted to use it.
So he was never interested in
the follow-up in that regard.
When he had those
lantern slides made,
and he wanted those
sometime colored,
it would have more impact,
they were colored by --
he never worked in a darkroom.
He used the camera.
Then he went -- he took his
pictures to a commercial studio.
They made prints that he would
then give to his publishers.
They made his lantern slides.
I want a lantern
slide of this or that.
Make this hand-colored or that.
He just didn't have a modern
sensibility about photography
at all, so -- and he only used
the camera for five years.
I mean, he was -- this is a
guy who wrote dozens and dozens
of articles, 13 books, was
a really skillful writer.
And, you know, the
cameras were --
the images were critical
because of the lectures.
I mean, they were
absolutely critical.
They're really not
critical in his books.
And they're almost not
commented on by reviewers.
But the lectures were -- he was
really aiming at those lectures.
And as I say, as soon
as he could get the photographs
he needed, and by that I mean --
I have no idea who
the photographers are.
You know, there were two
by Jessie Tarbox Beals
who's quite well-known,
and seven in 1911 that
he acquired of Lewis Hine
from the National Child
Labor Committee that appeared
in one article in Scribner's
in 1911, which was a summary
of the social reform
in the country.
But other than that,
there are just, you know,
pictures that were clearly
like a public school's
that were commissioned
by the Board of Ed or,
you know, things like that.
I mean, so he wasn't
really collecting --
there's no indication that
he was collecting photographs
with an eye to the images,
just to the subjects.
Yes.
>> How do you graphically
diverse for his lectures?
Did he [inaudible]
to give lectures?
>> Bonnie Yochelson: No.
He travelled the country.
There were these
-- he travelled --
he started out locally
because that was, you know,
he was just -- whatever
could come up he actually --
there was a mission
on the Bowery
that actually helped him
book his earliest lectures.
It was -- this mission
actually lent him money
to have his first
group of slides made.
And then they actually
publicized his lectures
in the area, in the
New York area.
And the scrapbook shows
his going to Connecticut,
he's going to New Jersey,
sometimes to Pennsylvania, and,
you know, very locally.
But later, when he really
started lecturing his way
to make money, that's when
he took these national tours,
and he spent three or
four months on the road.
And they'd be booked by
these lecture bureaus that --
and he travelled everywhere.
And one of the nice things in
the exhibition are the postcards
that he sent home to his
daughter Katie that are
from the Grand Canyon,
from the South,
from the North, from
the Northwest.
You know, he travelled
everywhere.
And it's really extraordinary
to think
about because this is the --
you know, this couldn't
have happened
without the lantern slide
and it couldn't have
happened without the train.
And one of the objects in
the exhibition that belongs
to the Museum of the City
of New York that's here
on view is his lantern
slide box.
It's just a cardboard
box covered in canvas.
And it's really,
really worn, you know.
So he carried that box of
slides with him on the train,
all over the country
several months a year.
And he had a heart condition.
He had a pretty serious
heart attack when he was 60,
and he was told to slow
down, and he didn't.
And he continued, and he was
constantly going on tours
at a sanitarium in --
I want to say Michigan.
I'm -- Barbara, you probably
know better than I do.
I can't remember.
But, anyway.
So he was constantly having
to be -- having a forced rest.
But he ended up dying
of a weak heart at 65.
So he never stopped.
But it was really just that --
he did travel to Europe several
times, but his travelling
to Europe was more to see
his family in Denmark.
And then he actually wrote a
tremendous amount about Denmark.
He wrote this crazy article
about Hamlet and Elsinore
and sort of saying because
there were all these --
because, you know, it's like
the truth about Shakespeare
in Elsinore, and he actually
went and found the documents
in the local -- it's
a crazy story.
He found the documents in the
local like City Hall that showed
when Shakespeare actually
visited Elsinore in Denmark
and then wrote this
article about it.
And he has a photograph
there, which he didn't take,
of Shakespeare's
tomb in Elsinore
which he says this
is a total fake.
It's there just for
the tourists.
You know. So, I mean, he --
his travel in Europe was more
like related to his
Danish identity,
although he was very involved
with English -- with English --
the English were very
progressive in terms
of social reform,
and he sometimes mentions
efforts that were done there.
So he made an effort to be.
But, as far as I know, he
didn't give talks there.
Yes.
>> In your talking
[inaudible] on [inaudible]
of documenting poverty
in the slums [inaudible]?
>> Bonnie Yochelson: Sure.
Let's see, how do I do this?
I mean, Riis took a
real hit in the 1890 --
in the 1990s, in the moment
of a sort of large attack
on the total humanist tradition
of documentary photography
saying
that photographers were
essentially making their own
reputations on the
backs of the poor.
So, you know, Dorothea
Lang, Eugene Smith,
a lot of these very famous
photographers were slammed hard,
and people turned to Riis
as like the beginning
of that criticism, of the
beginning of the tradition
that led to those photographers.
And, of course, the slum tour.
I mean, the name of his book,
How The Other Half Lives .
I mean, talk about
the other, you know.
I mean, he's identifying
from the get-go,
I am on one side describing
the poor to, you know,
describing the other half
to the well-off half.
I mean, that is the way
he frames that book.
And so the book was
heavily criticized for that,
as well as the racial
stereotyping.
What I found was that -- sort
of what my discovery was,
all of that is true, you
know, about that first book.
And that -- but then there
is that interesting shift
in the use of the camera with,
you know, immediately, you know,
in 1891 when he starts
photographing for Children
of The Poor he has
a completely different
relationship and, as
I say, a relationship
with his viewers that's very
personal and that's in line
with his writing which is,
in general, the storytelling.
He abandons the slum
tour entirely
after How The Other
Half Lives .
And, as I say, the second
book, which is more sort
of Marley sound in certain ways
was a complete flop as a book.
So, you know, people were not
interested in really learning
about the sentimental story
of Little Katie or, you know,
Little Eddie, the peddler, or,
you know, or a Buffalo who,
you know, was a shoeshine boy.
These wonderful tales and
their portraits fill that book.
And that didn't catch on
with the general public.
And people actually
liked the slum tour.
They wanted that sort of
peek-a-boo of the other half.
But that's what's wo
interesting about his --
the second best-seller
because that is really a
contemporary view.
When she tells his own
story, his own tell-all.
I was a homeless, I was
a homeless immigrant.
I got thrown out of a
police lodging house.
That is so interesting.
It's not really about
the photography anymore.
But in terms of approach
to the subject of poverty,
that's something that
is very much in line
with more contemporary
ideas of, you know,
of people representing
themselves.
And I -- as opposed to
having other speak for them
or others represent them.
And that is so interesting.
I find that really fascinating.
It's no longer really
about photography.
It's just about
self-representation and how
to affect people, how to
get people moved to care
about the problems of the poor.
And it may be, and this is like
totally armchair psychology
on my part, but, you
know, by the time he wrote
that book he was famous.
By the time he wrote
that book he was friends
with Teddy Roosevelt
in the White House.
And only from that position
of security was he
willing to tell that story.
When he wrote How The
Other Half Lives ,
his social status was much less
clear and much less secure.
And so by his identifying
himself in that earlier book as,
well, I'm one of you, he doesn't
tell the tale that he stayed
in a lodging house
in that, you know --
and that he was thrown out on
the street in a lodging house.
He didn't tell that story in
How The Other Half Lives .
Rather, he says, oh, let me
tell you about the Chinese,
let me tell you about
the Jews, let me tell you
about the Bohemians,
as a newspaper man,
as someone who knows this
world through my work,
not through my own experience.
So that's the kind
of shifts that I see
that are really important.
And, again, though, again and
again, I mean, when I give talks
on the [inaudible]
show in New York,
there was already
somebody saying, well,
wasn't he like a
bad guy, you know?
Aren't these photographs
really unethical, you know?
And all I can say is yes.
But what he's -- a more, a more
in-depth study shows that his,
you know, his ideas about reform
and representation
changed over time.
>> Guy Lamolinara: Wrap it up.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Bonnie Yochelson: Thank you.
Thank you, Aimee.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.